in chemistry we're going to see
situations where a molecule an entire
molecule itself might be neutral but
because of the differences in
electronegativities
and how the molecules are structured you
might have a partially positive charge
on one side and a partially negative
charge on another side and the most
famous example of that is a water
molecule a water molecule these have
three molecule water molecules depicted
here with the white oxygen molecule in
the center and the two hydrogens right
over here and this is the shape of the
water molecule sometimes you'll see it
with these electron pairs on the
on the other end from the oxygen from
those from those hydrogens but what's
interesting at least in the course of
this discussion about a water molecule
is even though the entire molecule is
neutral you have a total of 10 protons
and 10 electrons in total even though
it's neutral because of this shape and
because
the oxygen is more electronegative you
can end up with a
a more positive charge on one end and a
more negative charge on the other end
and just to reinforce this we look at
the periodic table and we know in
general as we go to the top right we get
more and more electronegative and oxygen
is one of the most electronegative
of the elements it's a good bit more
electronegative than hydrogen right over
here and so in this situation in this
water molecule the electrons in the
covalent bond between the hydrogen and
the oxygen are actually going to spend
more time are going to spend more time
around the oxygen i could draw something
like something like this they're going
to spend more time around here because
oxygen likes to hog the electrons more
than the hydrogen does and so what it
would do is it form a
you could say a partial negative charge
at the side of the molecule away from
the hydrogens and a partial positive
charge
on the sides where the hydrogens are
and this situation where you have a
separation of positive and negative
charges within a molecule this is called
a molecular dipole let me write that
down
molecular
molecular dipole and in a physics class
you might study the general idea of a
dipole and this is an electric dipole
where you have a separation of your
positive and negative charges in this
case we call it a molecular dipole
because it's of course across the short
space of an actual molecule this should
not be confused with a magnetic dipole
which we might also talk about in other
videos now in a water molecule the
dipole is a permanent dipole because
we're not changing electronegativities
here the oxygen just likes to hog those
electrons more and so this situation let
me write this this is a permanent
permanent
dipole and because of this permanent
dipole amongst this water molecules
that's what allows these water molecules
to be attracted to each other
so this molecule right over here this
end is going to be partially negative
this part n is going to be partially
positive
this lowercase delta here is how we
denote that partial charge and
those look like eights let me write them
a little bit neater
so partially negative
and partially positive
right over here this would be partially
positive partially positive
partially negative and so because of
this permanent dipole of the water
molecules you can have attraction the
partially negative char sides are going
to be attracted to the partially
positive charges and these are the
famous hydrogen bonds of water
so
that is
of h2o so that's going to be yeah i drew
most of the attraction that you see over
there
now all molecular dipoles don't have to
be permanent
so here is a depiction of some methane
molecules methane is ch4
and you see in methane that the carbon
is bonded somewhat symmetrically you
have this tetrahedral shape where the
the hydrogens are evenly distributed
they're getting as far away as they can
from each other so there's not it's a
very symmetrical in three dimensions
shape and also carbon and hydrogen's
electronegativities aren't that far
apart carbon is a little bit more
electronegative but because they're
close and there's this symmetry to the
actual molecule there isn't a a
permanent dipole in this situation
however you have to remember these
electrons are that are that are buzzing
around between these bonds and around
the nuclei of the different atoms they
they aren't just staying in one place at
any given time you might have
you might have some of the electrons
more on this side of
more on this side of this of this
molecule
and so you'll have a temporary partial
negative charge there may be a temporary
partially positive charge there
and that might be the exact same time
that this molecule that this molecule
right over here has
this molecule right over here maybe its
electrons happen to be more distributed
more in that direction so it's partially
negative partially
negative there and partially positive
here and so when you have just these
these random dipoles form at just a
certain moment in time just based on at
that moment how the electrons are
distributed we call that a temporary
dipole
temporary
dipole and those temporary dipoles can
create these temporary forces between
molecules and we studied that in other
videos the famous london dispersion
forces right at the moment that this one
is partially negative and this one is
partially positive
maybe that's right at the moment that
this one is partially negative at this
side and partially positive at this side
so the electrons are spending a little
bit more time here and so they might be
attracted to each other and not only
could it just be a temporary thing it
could also be induced if this one just
happens to be in that state and it's
partially positive on this side well the
electrons here on this molecule will be
naturally attracted so it might be an
induced dipole
and you could have uh to be more
explicit induced dipoles because of an
external force of the environment like a
electric field you could have an induced
dipole let's say you have a let's say
you have a molecule of h2o right over
here and let's say you have a molecule
of
neutral
neutral methane
right over here and that neutral methane
you know its electrons are moving around
but it has no permanent dipole
but as it gets near this water molecule
right over here well it has a permanent
dipole where it has a positive charge
here so maybe the methane molecules
electrons might be attracted more to
that to that positive charge and so this
situation where you take something that
otherwise would only maybe have
temporary dipoles
but because its electrons might be
attracted to something or repelled from
something
here you could have an induced
you could have an induced
dipole
and dipoles actually don't just happen
to be with multi-atom molecules you can
even have not permanent dipoles but you
could have induced or temporary dipoles
from a single atom let's say we were to
take an atom of argon the noble gases
are famously non-reactive so let's say
that this is one atom of argon let's see
that's its electro electron cloud let's
say that's its nucleus there and this is
a huge oversimplification
and you could imagine at just some
random point the electrons are just a
little bit more distributed on that side
and so you have this temporary dipole
that would form where you're more
negative here and more
positive right over here and of course
if this is next to something they might
be able to interact with each other if
this is maybe you could even induce this
it might not be random it might be
induced by a by a polar molecule nearby
something with a permanent dipole or it
might be induced by a magnetic field
well i'll leave you there but this idea
of molecular dipoles whether they're
permanent induced or temporary it's a
really neat idea because it actually
explains a lot of the properties of
molecules their boiling points their
freezing points how hard it is to get
them to get into a gaseous state versus
a liquid versus a solid state we'll see
a lot of that in chemistry